la déléguée à la vie associative de la
ddjs la direction de la jeunesse et des
sports en martinique et dans son crédit
ce matin bonjour céline renaud tuerie ti
bonjour n'en rêviez le temps il est
question de la quinzaine de l'engagement
avec vos de l'engagement des jeunes
c'est à dire l'engagement des jeunes on
est sur une quinzaine on a souhaité la
ddjs et s est made in john ambition
faire un focus particulier sur
l'engagement des jeunes en martinique
c'est-à-dire les différentes formes que
peuvent prendre ses engagements au
travers de dispositifs différents comme
le service civique comme les juniors
associations comme aujourd'hui par
exemple on a un focus plus particulier
dans les établissements scolaires au
tour des élèves père autour de tout ce
qui est conseil académique
les lycéens l'objectif pour nous c'est
de montrer que les jeunes dans
martinique s'engage qu'ils ont aussi une
une envie une volonté de travailler pour
le pays pour le pour la martinique pour
la société puisque l'engagement c'est
avant tout ça ça rime pas forcément avec
le volontariat
alors si mon nom le l'engagement c'est
pas forcément quelque chose enfin nous
on parle de volontaires parce que c'est
quelque chose qui qui est qui est un
petit peu cadré mais c'est du bénévolat
aussi ses différents statuts donc le
bénévolat le volontariat ça peut être
aussi des engagements complètement
informel quelqu'un qui est donne un coup
de main à ses voisins pour nous c'est
aussi une forme d'engagement et on n'est
pas obligé d'être dans un cadre posé et
formalisé j'ai une philosophie derrière
tout cela vous aimez bien le rappeler
c'est qu'on a toujours quelque chose à
donner on a toujours quelque chose à
recevoir s'il ya la transmission
l'objectif c'est effectivement ça c'est
que lorsque on s'engage pour une cause
enfin l'engagement c'est une voûte
quelque chose de volontaire c'est c'est
quelque chose que l'on a envie de faire
c'est un libre choix
de consenti d'aller vers un projet
d'accompagner un projet c'est défendre
des valeurs parce que souvent c'est
aussi ça c'est à voir pour soi des
valeurs que l'on souhaite mettre d'un
servir quelque part et puis c'est aussi
pour soi parce que on donne à la société
mais la société aussi renvoi quelque
chose c'est à dire que ça permet aussi
de grandir de développer des compétences
nouvelles de développer des compétences
que l'on pourra ensuite ré exploiter
dans sa vie personnelle dans sa vie
professionnelle aussi donc c'est les de
donner recevoir
si on s'engage si on se sent prêt à y
aller c'est parce qu'il ya une base dans
dans l'éducation reçue l'image peut être
des parents on pense qu'on a fréquenté
la vie associative
il y a de cela oui il ya une forme
d'exemplarité
mais on a aussi des découvertes c'est à
dire que on a plein de domaines dans
lesquels on peut aussi trouver des
engagements c'est pas forcément
uniquement le jeu c'est très vaste
oui c'est très très vaste 1 le maire
junior de telles villes de martinique ou
bien celui qui dit qui s'engagent dans
l'école d'arbitrage de son club de sport
c'est du volontarisme c'est de
l'engagement ses deux lancers de
l'engagement oui on a plein de formes
d'engagement différencier dans des
dispositifs précis que l'on soit bain au
niveau du volontariat de service civique
au niveau du volontariat européen
on a aussi comme vous l'avez dit des
conseils municipaux de jeunes on allait
déléguer les délégués quand on est
délégué d'une classe c'est déjà une
forme d'engagement on a les conseils de
quartier on a les bénévoles associatifs
par exemple le lit dans un groupe de
carnaval dans un orchestre de rue exact
menacé de l'engagement à partir du
moment où on a un projet collectif et
que individuellement s'engage au sein de
ce projet collectif on met plus tard
dans la vie
lorsqu'on va présenter son coeur qu'il
invitait un éventuel employeur est ce
que le fait de dire que on a été dans
une école d'arbitrage qu'on a arbitré ou
bien qu'on a fréquenté un orchestre de
rue est ce que ça pèse de la même façon
ça pèse de la même façon après c'est la
manière dont on le présente c'est
toujours pareil des compétences que ce
soit en termes d'arbitrages où que ce
soit dans un orchestre de rue on va pas
développer les mêmes choses
on va toujours développé des compétences
qui seront au service des autres et que
l'on peut se mettre à profit au service
de soi même et dans un cv ben si on
cherche quelqu'un de créatif on va
peut-être plus à l'est vers le musicien
de rue si on cherche quelqu'un qui est
peut-être un petit peu plus de rigueur
effectivement c'est peut-être plus la
notion d'arbitrage qui sera qui sera
mise en avant alors une chose est sûre
c'est que de toute façon ce seront des
expériences qui serviront après ça vous
tenez à le souligner oui pour nous ses
skis et ski c'est ce qui est important
c'est que on a en ahl témoignages aussi
on a le retour de deux jeunes qui sont
passés dans des structurations
associatives ou qui se sont engagés ça
sert toujours ça sert toujours parce que
on le met toujours un moment donné de sa
vie on a toujours cette cet engagement
là qui revient sur le devant
puisque ce sont des valeurs que l'on
transmet et puis ce sont surtout des
compétences que l'on va je dirais mettre
en action c'est à dire que on peut avoir
beaucoup de théorie on peut avoir
beaucoup de deux choses qu'aucun
enflammé dans le cambouis exactement là
on mettra en pratique les choses on
l'est on sort on se confrontera aussi à
la réalité parce que c'est aussi ça
c'est que quand on est engagé dans une
association dans un service des autres
on est face à la réalité on doit aussi
développer soi-même des désastres six
iep à la construction de l'individu
aurait peut-être dû commencer par là
céline renaud tuerie ti un
je-ne-sais-quoi jeunes qui peut
s'engager c'est de gainage à quel âge
par exemple alors il n'y a pas d'âge
pour commencer à st gall et moi j'aime
dans sa tête mais non bien sûr que nous
la tranche d'âge
en général on parle de 15 30 ans mais on
peut déjà on allait les touts les toutes
les tous les maires les maires juniors
ça peut démarrer à bien avant cela on a
des jeunes qui sont là des 11 12 ans
quand on est délégué à partir de la
sixième on
donc ça peut démarrer très jeune et ça
peut faire nous l'idée c'est qu'une fois
qu'on a ce mellal cette envie là elle
continue tout au long de la vie
l'engagement c'est une nouvelle idée des
autorités pour venir en aide aux
associations que le trou mais le
traumatisme des contrats aidés par
exemple de la main d'oeuvre corvéable à
souhait ah là là c'est un vaste débat
mais non on va pas on va pas rentrer sur
ce jeu là puisque l'engagement n'a pas
attendu la fin des contrats aidés pour
exister l'engagement associatif ou
l'engagement dans différents dispositifs
il existe depuis longtemps et c'est pas
forcément les contrats aidés et on n'est
pas sur les mêmes statuts oui c'est ça
l'histoire a précisé nous le statut de
de ces personnes qui s'engagent il ya
plusieurs strates il ya plusieurs stades
il ya simplement l'individu qui
s'engagent de manière informelle ça
c'est le premier premier stage stade
pardon on a aussi tout ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'engagement bénévole
donc on a l'habitude de dire que le
bénévolat c'est un engagement gratuit et
avec un ce qu'on appelle un lien de
coopération c'est ça qui est important
c'est qu'on n'est pas dans le travail on
est dans un lien de subordination là on
est sur un lien de coopération donc
c'est vraiment du donnant donnant entre
deux parties et on a un troisième statue
qui a paru un peu plus récemment qui est
celui du volontaire donc le volontaire
c'est un statut un peu hybride puisque
c'est quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
du liens de coopération toujours mais
qui va pouvoir avoir une indemnisation
et des cueillettes d'argent il ya
forcément des contrôles sketches comme
le fonds publics
une association ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi cette association aura
des droits et des devoirs tout à fait
tout le monde a toujours des droits et
des devoirs que ce soit au niveau de
l'association de la structure d'accueil
au niveau du jeune également donc quand
on parle notamment du dispositif le
enfin le plus connu au niveau du
volontariat c'est celui du service
civique
les associations ou les structures qui
accueillent des services civiques
doivent avoir un agrément préalable que
la djs et s dunn et pour cela il y a
effectivement tout une phase
d'accompagnement de notre part pour
vérifier que la mission est bien
d'intérêt général et après il y as
tutorat aussi tout au long le jeune
n'est pas lancer tout seul face à lui
même il est aurait il y à des temps de
formation aussi qui sont demandés et
puis nous s'il y avait un souci
quelconque on est bien sûr à même de
venir discuter aussi avec le jeune avec
l'association pour où la structure pour
essayer d'aller mieux on a constaté
qu'il ya beaucoup d'associations qui ont
recours à ce service civique est ce que
ces associations sont au courant de
toutes ces subtilités de la
réglementation est ce qu elles savent ce
qu'elles peuvent faire ce qu'elle doit
faire
alors on essaye de les accompagner au
mieux par rapport à ça après il ya tout
un guide clairement établie par rapport
à cette a7 à ce format de dispositifs on
est là aussi nous dans le rapport humain
on a aussi les missions locales qui
accompagne en a aussi d'autres disent
faire valoir d'autres acteurs autour qui
essaye d'accompagner ont fait beaucoup
de communication aussi autour de
dispositions qu'ils ont créé les moyens
de finir cette complication près de
toutes ces associations martinique par
exemple on essaye de le faire au mieux
avec les moyens que l'on a en termes
nous sur les agréments locaux que l'on
gère
le contact est quasi systématique avec
la structure donc on a quand même
toujours une phase de discussion avec
l'association pour vérifier que la
mission ait véritablement dans le dans
les pures de du dispositif est ce que
tous les engagements
disponible en martinique est ce que est
ce que tout a été recensée est ce qu'on
sait exactement qui fait quoi qui peut
faire quoi et qui fera quoi non c'est là
ma vie de ces la magie de l'engagement
justement c'est qu'il ya plein de
formats différents autant sur les
services civiques ça c'est assez calibre
et puis ce qu'on a on a des données
enfin voilà il ya un cadrage qui fait
qu'on a on peut compter statistiquement
mais ce serait difficile de
comptabiliser le bénévolat c'est neuf
c'est justement tout là toute la voilà
toute la difficulté c'était même pas une
difficulté pour moi c'est justement tout
la facilité de du bénévolat c'est qui
peut être émergents sans qu'on le
connaisse et c'est ça qui fait des gens
qui nous écoutent c'est qui ce qu'ils ne
savent pas que des expériences de passer
pourraient être des éléments
enrichissant de devant un employeur par
exemple exactement c'est sûr cela qu'on
travaille énormément nous sur justement
ce qu'on appelle lé entre guillemets le
cv citoyens c'est à dire de montrer
aussi ou non au travers d'un cv au delà
de la formation la qualification qu'on a
des compétences qu'on peut mettre tout à
fait à profit et que l'on est allé
chercher dans ses expériences
d'engagement et de bénévolat l'autre
espère qu'on n'a pas évoqué c'est que
vous voulez absolument changer le regard
des adultes sur les jeunes parce qu'on
est parfois sévères avec nos jeunes
c'est cela nous fait vraiment seulement
voilà on souhaite montrer une image
positive parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
toujours un peu tendance à stigmatiser
la jeunesse alors qu'il en existe
plusieurs formes at de jeunesse et nous
notre objectif c'est de dire que on a
aussi plein plein de jeunes qui vont
bien et qui s'engage et qui sont au
service de la société et qui
sont aussi font partie du ciment de
sociétal et qui le sont aussi des
constructeurs pour aujourd'hui déjà et
pour demain on va rappeler quand même le
slogan de cette quinzaine créé conçoit
construit agit on a tout résumé avec 60
ans tous régimes et avec ce slogan
cécile c'était l'objectif on part de l'
envie et on arrive jusqu'à la
construction
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
céline euro note urruty on rappelle que
vous êtes
la déléguée à la vie associative de la
direction de la jeunesse et des sports
en martinique et que nous avons parlé de
la quinzaine de l'engagement
merci ma journée